Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Salut tout le monde, ça faisait deux mois que j'avais plus publié d'épisodes, c'était pas prévu du tout.
D'abord, il y a eu plusieurs invités qui ont annulé et puis à côté de ça, j'avais aussi beaucoup de choses à gérer dans ma vie privée, professionnelle, tout ça.
J'ai eu une chirurgie aussi, donc j'avais vraiment besoin de souffler. Vraiment, je suis désolé pour ça. La bonne nouvelle, c'est que maintenant, on est reparti et que j'ai pu booker des invités vraiment intéressants pour ce début d'année 2020.
Je vous reparle de ça à la fin de cet épisode. Alors cette semaine, je reçois Corinne Torrekens. Corinne Torrekens, elle est professeure en sciences politiques et chercheuse à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles depuis 2003,
où elle travaille principalement sur un ensemble de questions liées à l'islam en Belgique et en Europe.
Je l'ai retrouvée dans son bureau au Solbosch pour discuter ensemble des musulmans de Belgique, de qui ils sont, de leur histoire et des stéréotypes dont ils sont sujets.
On parle aussi des évolutions que connaît l'islam en Belgique avec une appropriation de la religion par ses pratiquants, avec une sécularisation grandissante et avec aussi l'apparition d'un féminisme musulman.
C'est parti. Corinne Torrekens, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour nos auditeurs qui ne vous connaissent peut-être pas ?
Oui, donc je suis professeure de sciences politiques à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles et je travaille depuis une grosse quinzaine d'années sur toutes les questions relatives à l'insertion de l'islam en Belgique et plus largement en Europe.
L'insertion de l'islam en Belgique. Alors, vaste question dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui. Avant de se lancer au cœur du sujet, peut-être parler un petit peu de vous.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amenée à vous intéresser à cette question-là, vous, personnellement ? Quel est votre rapport à l'islam ?
Ah, c'est une bonne question. C'est une question difficile en fait, à laquelle j'ai des difficultés à répondre. En fait,
c'est assez simple. Lorsque j'étais adolescente, je fréquentais plutôt une école qu'on va qualifier d'assez élitiste, mais j'avais pas mal de copines
d'origine marocaine, d'origine algérienne, d'origine turque et de copains aussi.
Et ben tout ça a amené une série de questions sur des pratiques culturelles et religieuses différentes et donc un intérêt de ma part et intérêt qui n'a fait que grandir.
Et donc lorsque je suis entrée à l'université, j'ai vraiment eu à cœur de suivre toute une série de cours.
J'ai eu des cours absolument extraordinaires sur la doctrine islamique qui était donnée à l'époque en faculté de philosophie.
Et tout ça m'a amenée à grandir et à essayer de travailler cette question et d'essayer de peut-être, grande ambition, une sorte de pont entre les incompréhensions de part et d'autre d'ailleurs.
Mais donc, vous avez commencé en évoquant donc l'école élitiste dans laquelle vous étiez. Est-ce que vous mentionnez ça parce qu'il y avait un rapport difficile à l'islam dans cette école-là ou qu'est-ce que...
Non, il y avait pas forcément un rapport difficile par rapport à l'islam, mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait déjà des questions qui se posaient.
Donc par exemple, est-ce qu'on fait une place ou est-ce qu'on accorde un traitement pas particulier ou de faveur, mais voilà, est-ce qu'on se préoccupe de Ramadan, par exemple, hein.
Les élèves, lorsqu'on est en cinquième ou en sixième secondaire. Moi, j'avais pas mal de copains, de copines qui jeûnaient ou alors, on avait une retraite, bon c'était une école catholique.
Donc comme quoi, on peut faire l'école catholique et finir professeure à l'ULB, ça fonctionne. Mais voilà, le Ramadan tombait dans des périodes de retraite spirituelle, etc.
Et donc, ben j'avais des copines qui voulaient pas y aller parce que justement, c'était Ramadan. Et lors de ces voyages-là, il y avait la question du port qui pouvait se poser.
Puis on avait un professeur de religion, je me souviens très bien, en troisième secondaire, qui obligeait-- on devait faire la prière hein, à chaque cours.
Et donc, il obligeait les élèves qu'il savait bien musulmans à joindre les mains et à réciter la prière catholique.
Mh.
Ça pouvait quand même être considéré comme, voilà, comme de la violence symbolique. Et bien moi, ce sont toutes des questions qui déjà,
stimulaient mon intérêt, m'interrogeaient et sur lesquelles, voilà, après, j'ai eu envie de travailler.
Ouais, donc si je ne dis pas de bêtises, enfin, j'ai le sentiment qu'il y a un petit peu l'envie d'enquêter sur une sorte d'injustice, une sorte d'oppression. C'est-
Très clairement. Je pense que dans ma famille, on avait des représentations, des incompréhensions par rapport à certaines pratiques culturelles et religieuses.
Et à l'inverse, on avait peut-être aussi dans les familles de mes copains et de mes copines, des représentations un petit peu caricaturales de ce qu'on pouvait être, de ce qu'on pouvait faire.
Et donc ça m'a beaucoup interrogée, cette existence d'incompréhension mutuelle. Et c'est ça que j'ai voulu travailler.
La population musulmane bruxelloise, les chiffres, quels sont-- voilà, je sais que c'est une question qui revient tout le temps, mais quelle est la prépondérance, voilà, des musulmans à Bruxelles ?
Donc, cette population musulmane à Bruxelles, elle est importante pour plusieurs facteurs. D'abord,
c'est le témoignage de l'histoire même de l'immigration, c'est-à-dire qu'on était en présence d'une immigration majoritairement d'origine marocaine et d'origine turque.
Aujourd'hui, ça s'est largement pluralisé, notamment avec les immigrations plus récentes d'origine syrienne, d'origine irakienne, d'origine plus anciennement pakistanaise, tchétchène, etc.
Donc, il y a une pluralisation depuis dix, quinze ans. Mais sinon, historiquement, c'est majoritairement une immigration
d'origine marocaine et turque qui est le témoignage d'une immigration de main-d'œuvre, donc une immigration liée à un travail spécifique.
Travail plutôt lourd, plutôt dans la sidérurgie, plutôt dans les industries, etc. Et ces sphères d'emploi, elles étaient situées à Bruxelles dans certains quartiers précis.
Pour le dire platement, elles étaient assez peu présentes à Uccle-
Mmm-hmm, oui
...ou à Watermael-Boitsfort.
Au lieu de Saint-Pierre, oui.
Par contre, tout le long du canal, hein, par exemple-
Oui
...c'était cette zone-là. Donc ça veut dire que cette installation de cette population, elle témoigne du pourquoi de l'immigration.
Hein, c'est-- les autorités, il faut le rappeler, je pense, parce que nous sommes dans des sociétés de l'instantané et donc on a tendance à oublier notre histoire.
Faut pas oublier que le gouvernement belge a fait appel à cette immigration, a conclu des accords bilatéraux avec certains pays parce qu'il était à court de main-d'œuvre
et que le regroupement familial était considéré comme un moyen d'intégration.
Il était présent dans ces conventions bilatérales. Donc cette installation, elle témoigne de la fonction de cette immigration.
Et puis, elle témoigne aussi d'un autre mouvement qui est le mouvement largement décrit par mes collègues, par exemple, Kesteloot, de suburbanisation.
Ça veut dire qu'au moment où cette immigration, elle s'installe, eh bien, y a une partie de la population belge de souche bruxelloise, appelons-la comme ça, dans les années 60,
qui est plutôt issue de la classe moyenne, et le gouvernement va mener une politique d'acquisition de la propriété.
Et cette population bruxelloise, elle va quitter Bruxelles pour aller s'installer typiquement autour de Waterloo, à Rhode-Saint-Genèse.
C'est le mouvement de suburbanisation et de création de ces quartiers. Donc elle va acquérir une petite maison, quatre façades, petit jardin, petite, euh-
Un rabon.
Voilà. Donc Bruxelles voit une partie de sa population la quitter et cette population est en partie remplacée par la population immigrée dans les quartiers un peu plus populaires.
Parce que historiquement, Bruxelles avait déjà une ville haute et une ville basse, des quartiers hauts et des quartiers bas.
Donc toutes ces dynamiques s'enchevêtrent pour donner l'image de Bruxelles qu'on a aujourd'hui. Et donc cette immigration d'origine immigrée, largement musulmane, mais pas que, dans certaines communes.
On dit à peu près cinq communes bruxelloises sont très concernées par la concentration des populations d'origine immigrée et musulmane.
Là comme ça, on pense à Molenbeek, Schaerbeek, Laeken et euh-
Voilà, Saint-Josse-
Oui, c'est ça
...et Bruxelles-Ville, une partie de Bruxelles-Ville. Voilà, ce sont les communes qui sont les plus concernées, alors que d'autres communes vont être concernées par d'autres populations.
Si on regarde le schéma résidentiel des Français, par exemple, à Bruxelles, il est tout à fait en opposition avec le schéma résidentiel-
C'est ça. Les Français vont-
...des populations d'origine marocaine ou turque.
...plutôt s'installer à Woluwe.
Voilà.
Les Marocains vont plutôt s'installer à Molenbeek.
À Schaerbeek et à Molenbeek. Voilà, exactement.
OK. C'est très intéressant, voilà, le phénomène de suburbanisation que vous nous décrivez.
Je reviens néanmoins sur la question d'origine qui était : si on essaye de faire un pourcentage des musulmans qui vivent à Bruxelles, qu'est-ce que ça donne ?
Alors moi, je suis toujours embêtée par rapport à cette question de chiffres, parce qu'en fait, la réponse la plus honnête, c'est de dire qu'on ne sait pas.
Oui.
D'accord ? Et ça, je pense que c'est important. C'est important parce qu'en Belgique, comme dans d'autres pays européens, mais à l'inverse d'autres pays européens comme le Royaume-Uni, par exemple,
mais tout comme en France, on ne peut pas faire de statistiques religieuses.
Donc, dans les recensements, on ne peut pas poser la question de la filiation religieuse, que vous soyez bouddhiste, catholique, juif, musulman, peu importe, on ne peut pas vous la poser.
Ce qui veut dire qu'on est obligé de faire avec des estimations. Et des estimations sur base d'estimations, sur base d'estimations, sur base d'estimations.
Ça fait beaucoup d'estimations pour des scientifiques. Donc, on est obligé de passer par une proxy qui est l'origine immigrée, l'origine ethnique, donc de prendre les populations
qui ont la nationalité d'un pays où l'islam est la religion dominante, plus leurs descendants, plus l'origine ethnique.
Parce qu'évidemment, beaucoup de Marocains et beaucoup de Turcs et beaucoup d'autres nationalités ont acquis la nationalité belge dans les années 80 et dans les 90.
Donc, ils disparaissent de cette population qui a la nationalité d'un pays où l'islam est la religion dominante. Évidemment, ce sont devenus des Belges, donc on les retrouve plus.
Donc c'est compliqué. Donc on va se dire : voilà, on sait qu'il y a eu plus ou moins autant de Marocains et de Turcs auxquels on va ajouter un coefficient.
On va dire, ils ont eu plus ou moins, j'invente hein, 2,3 enfants. Puis la génération numéro deux, ils ont eu 1,8 enfants, etc.
Donc beaucoup d'approximations. Et en plus, si je comprends bien ce que vous dites, on fait l'équivalence entre une nationalité et une pratique religieuse.
Voilà, donc on fait beaucoup d'estimations. Donc il faut déjà prendre ces chiffres avec beaucoup de pincettes. Et puis, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On fait une ethnicisation du fait religieux. Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire : vous êtes d'origine marocaine, vous êtes d'origine algérienne, vous êtes d'origine turque, ça veut dire que vous êtes musulman ou musulmane.
Point à la ligne. Bah, si on faisait la même chose avec les personnes purement d'origine belgo-belge, gauloise, je sais plus ce qu'il faut utiliser comme terme, ça voudrait dire que toute cette population est catholique.
Bah, moi, ça me plairait pas trop qu'on me considère forcément comme étant catholique du fait de mon origine ethnique. Et pourtant, lorsqu'on le fait avec les musulmans, on a tendance à le faire.
Or, il y a des tas de personnes qui ont un background d'origine immigrée, qui sont d'origine marocaine, qui sont d'origine turque, qui se considèrent pas comme étant musulmanes, qui d'abord, qui peuvent, de fait, être,
catholiques ou juifs, parce que certains pays ont compté et comptent encore des minorités confessionnelles importantes, ou tout simplement ne peuvent se dire : « Bah voilà, je me reconnais pas comme étant musulman ou musulmane.
Je suis pas spécialement croyant. Et même si je suis un peu croyant ou que cette immigration a une importance, je suis pas pratiquant.
» Donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être musulman ou être musulmane ? Je pense qu'il y a un principe qui est important, c'est l'autodéfinition, c'est-à-dire
laisser la possibilité aux personnes de se dire oui ou non, je me considère comme étant musulman ou musulmane.
Donc quand on voit des chiffres comme ça, qu'on fasse vraiment très très attention. D'abord parce que c'est basé sur des estimations d'estimations.
Ensuite, qu'il y a l'ethnicisation du fait religieux et ensuite que ces chiffres sont quand même liés à un sentiment de menace et d'invasion. Attention-
C'est ça
...bientôt, ils seront majoritaires. Comment allons-nous faire pour vivre ensemble ?
Ben alors, je vais un petit peu mettre les pieds dans le plat. L'intérêt pour ces chiffres vient sans doute d'une certaine xénophobie, une certaine peur de la différence, ainsi de suite.
Mais je pense que ces chiffres sont liés, alors pas uniquement à une peur de type islamophobe ou xénophobe, etc.
Pour partie, elle est présente hein, mais elle est liée aussi à-- c'est difficile à expliquer, mais l'idée que lorsqu'on aboutit à, voilà, à Bruxelles, il y a trois cent mille musulmans ou quatre cent mille musulmans.
Ah maintenant, vous faites des chiffres.
Justement, je prends des chiffres fictifs hein.
Ah d'accord, OK. Donc ça, c'est clair.
Je me prononcerai pas sur des chiffres. Mais si on se dit : « Ben y a trois cent mille ou quatre cent mille musulmans », mais on produit une étiquette.
C'est-à-dire que le terme musulman, c'est tous les mêmes. Et moi, je passe énormément de temps avec mes étudiants ou en conférence à ouvrir cette boîte et ouvrir cette étiquette.
Ah OK, on aurait en Belgique hein, selon des statistiques qui m'énervent un petit peu et je pense que la dernière est passée, c'était il y a deux ou trois ans dans SudPresse, sept cent quatre-vingt-sept mille huit cent soixante-deux musulmans.
Donc c'est au musulman près quand même hein, y a pas de marge d'erreur possible. Eh bien, on aboutit à cette étiquette que les musulmans, c'est tous les mêmes.
Alors, on va ouvrir. OK. Alors, on a des sunnites ou des chiites.
Mh.
C'est intéressant, ça. Les sunnites et les chiites, ben, c'est pas pareil. C'est pas la même chose. Ils croient pas à la même chose.
Ils sont même parfois en conflit. Alors majoritairement, on va se dire qu'on a des sunnites. Certainement quatre-vingt-cinq, nonante pour cent du monde musulman est sunnite.
OK. Alors dans les sunnites, on a les écoles juridiques qui sont pas les mêmes. Les Turcs font pas partie de la même école juridique le plus souvent que les Marocains.
Ah tiens, c'est intéressant, ça. Après, on a des origines ethniques. On vient de parler des Marocains et des Turcs, mais les Pakistanais aussi, c'est super intéressant.
Il y a les Tchétchènes. C'est pas le même islam.
Bon, donc il y a une pluralité dans le monde musulman.
Il y a une pluralité. Les intérêts politiques sont pas les mêmes, les intérêts socio-économiques sont pas les mêmes.
Et ça, je pense que c'est super important de s'en rendre compte parce que les intérêts sont différents et que donc quand on aboutit à des chiffres de trois cent mille, quatre cent mille, six cent mille, on gomme tout ça.
On gomme toute cette diversité interne et on laisse penser, on laisse croire qu'ils pensent tous pareil, qu'ils font tous pareil, etc.
Et ce n'est véritablement pas le cas.
Si on revient un petit peu aux sources de
ce que j'appellerais grossièrement une certaine xénophobie, on parle parfois d'islamophobie, qui vient sans doute, à vous de me le dire, mais sans doute aussi d'une peur de la différence et une protection d'une certaine culture, une certaine valeur.
Je pense au hasard au voile islamique, par exemple, qui fait beaucoup parler de lui, la question du féminisme dont on parle de plus en plus en Europe.
Et est-ce que le voile est vraiment compatible avec ça et ainsi de suite. Donc finalement, est-ce que cette position défensive, comment est-ce que vous la percevez ?
Est-ce que vous la comprenez ? Est-ce que vous la condamnez ? Est-ce que-- c'est difficile de...
Mais bien sûr qu'on peut que la comprendre dans une certaine mesure. C'est-à-dire qu'elle date elle aussi d'une bonne quinzaine d'années.
Les attentats du onze septembre vont avoir un effet largement dramatique dans la représentation de l'islam, de ce qu'est l'islam.
Et aujourd'hui, encore aujourd'hui, donc 2001, on est en 2020, si on regarde ce qui fait notre actualité médiatique autour de l'islam, hein, c'est des petits exercices qu'on peut faire assez facilement.
On introduit le terme islam dans des moteurs de recherche de médias. On va tomber soit sur toutes les questions liées au terrorisme et à la radicalisation, qui reste un vrai problème,
mais qui reste un épiphénomène aussi, mais qui, voilà, qui agite beaucoup la représentation médiatique de l'islam, où on va être en lien à des informations qui se déroulent dans des pays musulmans.
Par exemple, tout ce qui se passe en Iran,
ou tout ce qui peut se passer en Algérie et avec des questions qui sont parfois des questions tout aussi dramatiques, liées, par exemple, je prends un exemple là, aux applications,
très visuelles, très impressionnantes de la charia, de la loi islamique,
même si c'est beaucoup plus large que ça.
Donc forcément, lorsque ça fait près de vingt ans qu'on médiatise la question de l'islam de cette manière-là, ben ça finit par créer des représentations.
Et aujourd'hui, beaucoup de personnes en Belgique, ailleurs,
n'ont que très très peu de relations avec des personnes de confession musulmane,
si ce n'est via ce prisme médiatique qui représente quand même l'islam et les musulmans comme des moudjahidines avec des couteaux dans la bouche et des lapidations, découpage de mains, des femmes qui sont malmenées, etc.
Donc forcément, ça crée des représentations. Et donc c'est important, je pense aussi, de pouvoir réintroduire de la nuance ou de réintroduire les lames de fond qui sont présentes, qu'on peut observer, qu'on peut d'ailleurs,
analyser statistiquement aujourd'hui, c'est important.
Pas juste de dire : on a fait trois entretiens, mais statistiquement, de montrer qu'il y a des évolutions qui sont importantes
et qui, justement, démontrent que sur la question des valeurs, il y a un rapprochement très très fort, en tout cas par rapport à toutes les questions politiques.
Après, il y a des questions qui restent des questions extrêmement délicates et qui vont tourner autour des questions de sexualité de manière générale, donc homosexualité,
sexualité avant le mariage et toutes les questions relatives à ce qu'on pourrait appeler les questions de l'éthique de la vie : avortement, l'euthanasie, etc.
Un certain conservatisme alors-
Un conservatisme moral qui est encore extrêmement présent. Par contre, sur les valeurs politiques, démocratie, liberté d'expression, etc., on peut considérer que ces valeurs sont largement acquises.
Quand vous dites ça, je pense à Charlie Hebdo. J'ai personnellement ressenti une certaine vague de conservatisme et d'anti-- Tout le monde n'était pas Charlie dans le monde musulman francophone.
Donc ça se ressent là aussi, non ?
Oui, clairement. Alors, il y a une différence qui est fondamentale qui est de dire : « Je ne suis pas Charlie parce que l'épisode des caricatures du Prophète a été extrêmement loin.
» Et là, il y a tout à fait autre chose qui est de dire : « Je soutiens ou j'estime que l'attentat dont ils ont été victimes, ben en définitive, c'est bien fait.
» Donc, c'est un discours qu'on a pu entendre.
On a pu entendre les deux, oui.
Moi, je l'ai entendu clairement. Et donc ça reste totalement inacceptable, mais là aussi, il y a un peu-- en fait, on a un cadre théorique
qui nous aide en sciences politiques et sociales à comprendre ces phénomènes-là, c'est celui de la religiosité réactive.
Donc c'est l'idée que dans un, encore une fois, dans un discours, dans une période, dans un contexte
où le discours médiatique et politique est quand même extrêmement tendu et polarisé sur cette question-là, ça devient extrêmement difficile de débattre de la question de l'islam de manière sereine.
Regardez un peu politiquement toutes les déclarations auxquelles on a eu droit sous le précédent gouvernement. C'est quand même extrêmement impressionnant la manière dont
des hommes et des femmes politiques de premier plan, dont on pourrait considérer qu'une partie importante de leur mission est de protéger le cadre légal, et c'est-à-dire aussi
le cadre légal des lois anti-discrimination, ont repoussé les limites du dicible, de ce qu'il était possible de dire et de faire.
Et bien dans ce contexte qui est extrêmement tendu, on a tendance à avoir aussi des réactions de crispations identitaires extrêmement fortes.
Cette crispation identitaire, elle se fait de moins en moins sur le facteur ethnique et de plus en plus sur le facteur religieux, sur le facteur
de l'identité religieuse, alors que la pratique religieuse, elle n'est pas toujours extrêmement forte ou en tout cas, elle n'est pas forte sur toutes les pratiques religieuses.
Donc, on voit que c'est crispation identitaire sur l'identité religieuse. C'est une forme de retournement du stigmate de Goffman : « Ah, ça t'enquiquine que je sois musulman ou musulmane.
» Et bien, je vais deux fois plus être musulman, musulmane en l'affichant peut-être de manière beaucoup plus forte.
Donc un lien de corrélation ou même un lien de causalité entre discrimination, oppression, islamophobie et religiosité renforcée ?
Alors, c'est extrêmement débattu dans la littérature. Nous, dans nos données statistiques, dans les données statistiques qu'on a,
qui est le rapport, pardon, de la Fondation Roi Baudouin, que j'ai codirigé, qui s'appelle,
Belgo-Turcs, Belgo-Marocains, Autoportrait de nos concitoyens, on voit très clairement un lien statistique entre le sentiment de discrimination et une religiosité plus importante, une religiosité renforcée.
Mais par contre, je ne peux pas vous dire quel est le sens du lien. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a deux hypothèses. Les personnes sont plus visibles parce qu'elles sont plus religieuses.
Donc les femmes portent plus le foulard, les hommes peut-être plus la barbe, etc. Donc les facteurs visibles de l'islamité, et donc ont été ou se sont sentis plus discriminés dans l'espace public.
Ça, c'est une première hypothèse. Ou à l'inverse, les personnes ont été l'objet de discrimination et sont devenues plus religieuses.
Vous voyez, il y a deux liens possibles. Mais en tout cas, statistiquement, il y a un lien. Et ça veut dire que la manière dont
le débat public va continuer à se poursuivre, et bien ça veut dire qu'on aura un impact, tous, vous comme moi,
comme les hommes et les femmes politiques, on aura un impact sur la manière dont l'islam sera vécu et pratiqué dans quinze ans, dans vingt ans.
Et donc est-ce que ça veut dire que ceux et celles qui font l'équivalence entre une certaine modernité et une émancipation des croyances religieuses, voire même un effacement de la religiosité, en tenant ce genre de discours, finalement,
renforce l'identité religieuse des personnes concernées ?
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ?
Alors, je pense qu'il y a des choses vraiment très très différentes, et des différences importantes à faire. Je pense pas que ce soit une question de laïcité.
Pour être très claire, alors on a un discours laïciste extrêmement fort qui vient parfois, très souvent d'ailleurs, du contexte français hein.
On dit souvent que quand Paris s'enrhume, Bruxelles éternue, alors que le contexte belge est tout à fait différent.
C'est d'ailleurs c'est toujours très marrant d'aller expliquer aux Français qu'en Belgique, hein, on reconnaît les cultes, on les finance et on les organise.
Ce qui est évidemment l'antithèse du système français. Et pourtant, malgré ces différences de contexte, le débat français se répercute souvent en Belgique.
Donc on a un prisme laïciste. Or, ce qu'on voit en sociologie des religions, c'est que justement, le religieux ne disparaît pas.
Donc là, il y avait une thèse un peu évolutionniste de la conception de la modernité. C'est-à-dire qu'au plus nos sociétés se modernisent, au plus elles évoluent, au plus le religieux va disparaître.
En fait, ce qu'on voit, c'est que c'est pas le cas. D'abord parce qu'il y a eu un religieux transplanté, donc le religieux lié, amené par l'immigration, et pas que l'immigration musulmane hein, l'immigration
africaine, les évangélistes, etc., amène du religieux nouveau.
Donc le religieux ne disparaît pas, mais aussi au sein des personnes ou des populations qui ne sont pas issues de l'immigration, ce qu'on voit, c'est que le religieux s'est déplacé.
On a des objets de religiosité ou des objets de spiritualité qui se sont extrêmement développés. Je crois qu'on ne peut comprendre partiellement que la diffusion du yoga que dans cette perspective-là aussi, par exemple.
C'est que, eh bien, on a toute une série... L'engouement pour le bien-être, les coachs de, oui, de bien-être, de yoga, c'est justement parce qu'on voit que
les objets de-- on n'est plus dans la religiosité, mais dans la spiritualité.
Et donc ce religieux, ce qui perd en force, c'est le religieux institué. Très clairement-
On se l'approprie.
Les églises sont en perte de vitesse. C'est quelque chose qu'on voit aussi au sein des communautés musulmanes. On aurait tendance à penser le contraire.
En fait, non. Le religieux institué au sein des communautés musulmanes, il est aussi en perte de vitesse. Donc tout ça est en perte de vitesse.
Par contre, les croyances dans des objets, dans des formes de spiritualité, augmentent ou se maintiennent.
Donc, c'est ça qu'il faut voir.
À quoi est-ce que vous faites référence quand vous parlez de croyances dans des objets ?
Ben par exemple, on a des personnes qui peuvent, qui vont pas croire
en Dieu au sens monothéiste du terme, mais par contre, vont croire à la présence d'esprits, à la présence de forces, d'énergies, ce genre de choses.
Donc, on voit que les croyances ont bougé, les lignes ont bougé, mais on voit le maintien d'un certain nombre de croyances.
Donc tout ça pour dire que la thèse du désenchantement du monde, pour reprendre une thèse célèbre, la thèse de Marcel Gauchet,
eh bien, elle ne se vérifie pas entièrement et on assiste plutôt à un réenchantement du monde, pour reprendre une autre thèse, ou à un maintien des croyances de manière différente.
Mais donc il faut tordre un petit peu le cou à cette perspective évolutionniste. La modernité s'accompagne de la disparition du religieux. C'est faux.
C'est faux ?
Oui, c'est faux. Et on le voit bien, par exemple, je trouve ça toujours assez mignon. On a des prises de bec sur le religieux et sur le religieux autre, et souvent musulman, depuis une quinzaine d'années.
Mais par contre, c'est tout à fait mignon de voir, moi, dans la commune ou dans mes communes ou dans les communes dans lesquelles je circule le plus souvent, ben il y a la crèche sur la place communale.
Hein. Et c'est mignon de constater qu'en 2019-2020, la crèche va être moins considérée comme un objet purement religieux que comme un objet culturel.
Vous parlez de la crèche-
Bah la crèche de Noël. Voilà, le... Bon. Donc c'est-- et pourtant, de communes qui, par ailleurs, auraient tout à fait du mal...
Dans les communes où je vis, ça, la question se pose pas, mais je suis sûre qu'elles auraient bien du mal à organiser un abattoir temporaire pour la fête du sacrifice.
Au-delà des questions d'organisation pratique qui sont très difficiles,
mais sur la question purement principielle, en considérant que quand même, c'est une fête religieuse et est-ce qu'il appartient véritablement à la commune d'intervenir dans une fête religieuse.
Par contre, la crèche, il y a pas de souci, ça fait partie de la culture. Ça montre comment des objets religieux ou des cérémonies religieuses ou des événements religieux sont passés dans la culture populaire.
Et ce n'est pas encore le cas d'autres manifestations religieuses. Autant espérer que ce sera le cas un jour.
C'est aussi sans doute un phénomène électoral. Enfin, je veux dire, si une population musulmane extrêmement majoritaire, on pourrait sans doute voir ce phénomène apparaître, non ?
Alors, on peut le voir comme ça, mais moi, ce qui m'intéresse en tant que sociologue ou politologue du religieux, c'est de montrer, c'est de voir
comment et pourquoi certaines manifestations sont débattues, sont interrogées, posent problème et d'autres ne sont pas du tout interrogées.
Hein. Et très souvent, je pense que nos sociétés se représentent parfois elles-mêmes comme elles ne le sont pas. C'est-à-dire, parfois, on pense qu'on est des sociétés qui sont extrêmement tolérantes.
Hein. C'est pas tout à fait le cas. Si on reprend la question de l'égalité homme-femme-
Ouais.
Justement, en discussion avec le voile islamique, hein, où tout le monde tout d'un coup est féministe, c'est très intéressant.
Il faut quand même rappeler que nos sociétés sont structurellement patriarcales, que l'égalité homme-femme est loin d'être un fait établi, en ce compris jusqu'au plus haut niveau des universités, par exemple.
Et donc on se représente parfois de manière très avantageuse. On se pense comme étant areligieux et le religieux a disparu.
En fait, non, il est un petit peu partout, sauf qu'on ne le voit plus. Mais par contre, le religieux des groupes dominés, ah, celui-là, on le voit parce que peut-être, il nous gêne pour X ou Y raison.
Et c'est ça qui m'intéresse en tant-
X ou Y raison ?
Qu'observatrice. Ben parce que d'abord, on estime qu'il est pas de chez nous, bon sang de bonsoir, hein, et que donc il n'a pas le droit de citer.
Citer dans les deux sens du terme. Exister et a le droit à s'exprimer dans l'espace urbain.
Quand je pense à la population bobo bruxelloise, écolo, féministe et ainsi de suite,
je fais une équivalence, moi, personnellement, entre cette population-là et un effacement, voire même carrément un certain mépris pour l'enseignement catholique qu'ils ont connu ou autre.
Est-ce que c'est vraiment vrai, de dire que modernité n'équivaut pas à un effacement de la religiosité ?
Alors moi, je vais prendre, pour vous répondre, l'exemple justement des communautés musulmanes, ce qu'on voit... Donc, on voit très clairement un mouvement d'individualisation.
Ouais.
Et ce mouvement d'individualisation, on peut le démontrer d'un point de vue quantitatif. Ça veut dire qu'on a à la fois des niveaux de se considérer soi-même comme étant musulman ou musulmane qui sont des niveaux assez importants.
On a des niveaux de réponses à des questions comme : est-ce que c'est important pour vous ? Est-ce que vous êtes fier de cette identité qui sont assez importants, donc qui ont des pourcentages importants.
Et dans le même temps, on voit par exemple que toutes les pratiques religieuses ne sont pas suivies de manière équivalente.
Ça veut dire que si on essaye de regrouper, prenons ne serait-ce que les cinq piliers de l'islam, si on essaye et enlevons le pèlerinage parce qu'il représente une population spécifique.
Mais si on essaye de reprendre, de regrouper les principaux piliers et de les mettre ensemble dans le même outil statistique, on voit que ça fonctionne pas.
En français, dans le texte, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut dire que les personnes qui prient très régulièrement tous les jours ne fréquentent pas la mosquée.
Ça veut dire que les personnes qui prient ne font pas le ramadan ou à l'inverse, que les personnes qui font le ramadan ne prient pas forcément ou que les personnes qui disent, c'est pas un pilier,
vraiment que c'est très très important pour eux de consommer tout le temps halal, parce que ça ne se résume plus uniquement qu'à la nourriture aujourd'hui,
et bien ne se retrouvent pas forcément dans les personnes qui prient, qui font le ramadan, etc.
Ça, c'est une fragmentation, c'est de l'individualisation. Ça veut dire qu'on prend dans les dogmes, dans les pratiques religieuses, ce qui nous correspond, ce qui correspond à nos propres interprétations.
Une forme de bricolage quoi.
C'est du bricolage. Et donc qui n'est pas un terme péjoratif, c'est vraiment un terme qui est issu de la sociologie du religieux.
Donc ce bricolage qui était l'apanage des populations catholiques, aujourd'hui, on le voit au sein des populations musulmanes.
Qu'est-ce qu'on voit aussi ? On voit que, je le disais au niveau des valeurs politiques, on a une adhésion très forte aux valeurs politiques de la modernité occidentale.
Donc très concrètement, ça veut dire qu'on peut être totalement moderne dans sa conception de l'État démocratique, de la manière dont il doit fonctionner, et en même temps avoir une identité religieuse forte.
Tout dépend comment on définit la modernité alors.
Je pense qu'il faut faire attention aux conceptions normatives de la modernité. Ça veut dire-- et là, on voit qu'on voit des choses différentes, mais c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi.
Ça veut dire que nos sociétés ne sont pas que des sociétés où, voilà, c'est comme ça une fois pour toutes. Nos sociétés évoluent, elles changent, elles se métamorphosent, elles se modifient.
Donc la conception très évolutionniste qu'on avait de la modernité, ben on voit qu'elle ne correspond pas entièrement. Et tant mieux qu'on ait des personnes
qui sont complètement athées, qui sont totalement modernes, des personnes qui sont
plus agnostiques et qui sont totalement modernes et des personnes qui ont aussi une identité religieuse forte et qui n'ont pas un problème relationnel avec la question de la modernité.
On a un problème en Belgique qui est la question de la reconnaissance. Reconnaître que notre Belgique, elle est athée, elle est catholique, elle est juive, elle est bouddhiste, elle est aussi musulmane, protestante, etc.
Donc c'est aussi reconnaître ben qu'aujourd'hui, il y a une pluralité de la Belgique qui est musulmane et que ça restera comme ça et que ça ne changera pas.
Ensuite, il y a la question populiste. Et donc je pense que les propos que je condamnais il y a quelques minutes de cela, c'est pas le fruit de personnalités qui ont une conception très exclusive de la laïcité.
Ce sont des propos, des actes de personnes populistes. Et malheureusement, on a vu avec le précédent gouvernement des choses qui sont absolument incroyables.
Et j'ai encore du mal à expliquer aujourd'hui à des collègues européens, à des collègues d'autres universités européennes, comment et pourquoi le gouvernement n'est pas tombé
sous le coup de certains propos qu'ont pu tenir l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur ou l'ancien secrétaire d'État à l'asile et à l'immigration.
Tellement cela dépasse ce qu'on aurait pu penser et pourtant, c'est passé.
Là encore, sans doute un phénomène électoral. Enfin, je veux dire, ces propos sont sans doute, a priori, le reflet des électeurs.
Oui, sans doute, mais ce qui est impressionnant, encore une fois à observer, c'est qu'ils ont été l'objet d'assez peu d'indignation médiatique, en fait.
C'est qu'au fur et à mesure, c'est passé. Et donc, je pense qu'il faut, d'un point de vue analytique, c'est aussi quelque chose que je dis à mes étudiants ou en conférence, c'est qu'il faut arrêter de penser que
le discours politique, il reste en suspens dans l'air et qu'il ne produit pas des effets.
Les discours produisent des effets, ils produisent des effets politiques, ils produisent des effets en termes de comportement.
Et donc lorsqu'on a des personnalités politiques de premier plan qui s'autorisent, entre guillemets, des dérapages, ce ne sont pas des dérapages.
Ça consiste en stratégies de communication qui ont pour objectif de justement repousser les limites du dicible, de tester un petit peu les réactions.
Je pense qu'on n'a pas pris assez en considération
la catastrophe de ce que ça représente, parce qu'en définitive, ça légitime, ça autorise les personnes qui ont, voilà, les pensées les plus islamophobes, les pensées les plus racistes, à les exprimer au grand jour.
Et ça, c'est le moment politique dans lequel on est et on ne peut qu'appeler les hommes et les femmes politiques qui ont pour intérêt la chose publique et l'intérêt du commun à prendre conscience de cet état de fait.
Vous êtes de ceux et de celles qui pensent que
les actions, les déclarations du précédent gouvernement ont en quelque sorte légitimé des discours qu'on retrouve par exemple dans la bouche des extrêmes,
comme le Vlaams Belang, par exemple, et que ça, si je comprends bien, a directement
mené à leur succès électoral.
Oui, c'est un peu loin de mes compétences scientifiques. En tout cas, je suis très inquiète.
Moi, je fais partie des personnes qui sont inquiètes, par ce que je vois et ce que j'entends. Pourquoi ? Parce que moi, je fais partie de ceux qui en voient les effets.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a souvent l'image du prof d'université dans sa tour d'ivoire qui sort de temps en temps par la fenêtre pour voir l'état du monde.
Mais lorsqu'on donne cours, lorsqu'on donne énormément de conférences comme j'essaye de le faire à tous les publics, eh bien, on constate que ce discours, il fait son chemin.
Et donc il m'arrive de plus en plus d'être face à un public, non pas que je demande à venir en territoire conquis, mais venir à un public extrêmement dur, dont les représentations,
en particulier sur la question de l'islam, sont forgées dans le marbre et dont il devient très très difficile de pouvoir exposer un discours plus nuancé parce qu'il devient inacceptable.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'est plus entendable. Et ça, c'est quelque chose que je constate depuis deux, trois ans et c'est inquiétant, ça fait extrêmement peur.
Ça veut dire qu'on va en conférence avec des gants de boxe.
Mais donc justement, les appréhensions, les stéréotypes, voilà tous ces clichés qu'on peut avoir au sujet de l'islam.
Si on démêle un petit peu le vrai du faux, qu'est-ce que vous entendez régulièrement qui vous agace ? Les a priori typiques au sujet de la population musulmane bruxelloise avec un grand M ?
Je pense que très clairement, en tout cas depuis ces deux, trois dernières années, hein, c'est la question de la violence.
Oui.
C'est-à-dire que, ben forcément, le prisme de la radicalisation et du terrorisme a pris beaucoup d'ampleur. Et ce qu'on constate, c'est une forte polarisation des opinions, des opinions publiques européennes.
Et donc lorsque je suis amenée à dire,
à dire ce que je fais, eh bien, on a souvent tendance à voir l'islam et les musulmans sous le prisme du terrorisme et de la radicalisation ou plus largement, mais aussi de manière caricaturale,
sous le prisme de l'islamisme, c'est-à-dire musulman, islam égal islamisme, ce qui représente des mouvements tout à fait particuliers
et qui ne sont, à mon avis, pas représentatifs des tendances lourdes qu'on observe au sein des populations musulmanes européennes, mais qui occupent une place importante de l'espace médiatique et politique.
Les personnes musulmanes qui partent en Syrie, qui partent faire le djihad, quelle est leur démarche ? Quelle est leur situation ?
Comment est-ce qu'ils se retrouvent à prendre une décision comme celle-là ?
Alors, c'est-- Vaste question parce qu'il n'y a pas une seule réponse. Dans les entretiens qu'on peut faire avec ma collègue Fabienne Brion, on voit qu'il n'y a pas un profil ou il n'y a pas une situation.
Donc, très clairement, on a eu des personnes qui sont parties assez tôt. Je pense à 2012, 2013, par exemple, au moment où,
C'est pas encore très clair d'ailleurs sur la question, sur le territoire syrien, l'État islamique n'est pas encore--
Il est proclamé, mais pas dans la forme qu'on va connaître par la suite, mais en tout cas, ils sont aimantés par une question presque chevaleresque.
C'est-à-dire, le peuple syrien, qui est un peuple, qui est une population sunnite, est massacré, est opprimé par un régime qui, lui, est chiite et même une dissidence du chiisme, donc qui est la version hérétique des hérétiques.
Et donc un appel à la solidarité, un appel à venir aider sur place, quitte à combattre. Et pour beaucoup, dans ce cas-là,
il va y avoir deux phénomènes, c'est-à-dire soit un décès extrêmement tôt, parce que c'est souvent ce sont des jeunes, ils vont partir au front, ils vont mourir dans les premiers mois de leur séjour.
Et pour beaucoup d'autres, il va y avoir une désillusion extrêmement forte. Donc, pour reprendre les propos de l'un de nos interviewés,
il arrive sur place et il va constater assez rapidement que les différents groupes de la coalition anti-Bachar al-Assad se tirent entre les pattes, au propre comme au figuré.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une menace physique de mourir sous les balles d'un autre groupe de l'opposition à Bachar al-Assad.
Et donc l'illusion un peu romantique, un peu de dire : on fait partie d'une coalition, se fracasse assez rapidement.
Pour d'autres, ce qu'on leur a promis, l'idéal qu'on leur a promis, ils ne le voient pas sur place. Et donc il y a un désir de retour assez vite qui se fait.
Donc on a d'autres profils plus jusqu'au-boutistes, des profils plutôt de type suicidaire d'une certaine manière.
C'est-à-dire que ce projet permet de mourir en martyr et de mettre un point final à une existence faite de toute une série de difficultés, de parcours délinquants, par exemple.
Et donc le martyr permet de ne pas être jugé le jour du jugement dernier et donc d'effacer l'ardoise. C'est un profil qu'on a pu retrouver.
Des profils d'idéaux, c'est-à-dire, c'est difficile de vivre en tant que musulman en Europe. Tandis que dans un État islamique, ben c'est possible.
Et donc là, c'est un projet de vie. Ou des profils plus jusqu'au-boutistes au sens où il y a-- pour moi, ce sont des profils plus minoritaires,
mais qui peuvent interroger très fortement, c'est-à-dire des profils où ça répond à une recherche de violence, très clairement.
Recherche de violence, de pouvoir, voilà, de devenir quelqu'un sur place et d'avoir un peu de pouvoir quand on va-
Et alors, qui serait alors peut-être le résultat d'un certain culte, de la virilité, de la masculinité, de la force de-
Alors ça, on l'a retrouvé de manière générale. Il y a, ce sont-- on l'oublie souvent, mais c'est une idéologie dans laquelle les rapports de genre sont extrêmement délimités.
Il y a un rôle pour les femmes qui est très clair-
Oui
...celui de la reproduction, de la pudeur.
Je sais pas si on l'oublie souvent, mais oui.
Je pense que dans beaucoup d'analyses, on l'oublie.
D'accord, OK, oui.
Pourquoi ? Parce que on dit dans nos sociétés, justement, et c'est apparu de manière très claire avec le phénomène MeToo, qu'il n'y a plus un rôle pour les hommes et pour les femmes, que ces identités de genre sont
devenues plus floues.
Eh bien dans l'idéologie djihadiste, les identités de genre sont extrêmement claires. Je pense que pour certains profils, ça peut servir effectivement de quelque chose de très cadrant et de très structurant qui est rassurant.
Donc je pense que c'est l'un des éléments, c'est pas le seul évidemment.
Donc un retour à une forme de polarité très binaire, très cadrée, très claire-
Et très structurante.
Oui, c'est ça. OK.
Je pense que pour certains profils, ça a joué. Ce n'est pas le seul élément. Il faut voir cette idéologie, cette propagande, ces parcours véritablement en ayant un œil sur toute une série de facteurs.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Et donc il n'y a pas un seul facteur qui est déterminant, c'est une pluralité d'entre eux. Il faut arriver à les mettre tous ensemble dans le même schéma.
C'est ça qui est très difficile et qui demande un petit peu de temps.
Mh. Si on revient sur ce dernier aspect, la question des questions de genre, la vague MeToo en opposition à cette binarité plus rassurante, plus cadrante.
Quelle est la solution à ce moment-là ? Si on vient avec une certaine modernité, un certain féminisme, voilà, une émancipation des rôles genrés et que la population--
cette population-là bien précise réagit de manière défensive en se retranchant sur un vieux modèle, qu'est-ce que ça indique ?
Ça indique que-- ça a été mal introduit ? Ça doit être fait de manière plus diplomatique, plus douce ? Ça a été trop brutal ?
Mais je pense que justement, on va revenir en partie sur la question des chiffres et de la nuance.
Oui.
La question de la radicalisation en Belgique, la radicalisation de type djihadiste, c'est moins de 600 individus. D'accord ?
C'est ça, oui.
600 individus. Donc c'est un épiphénomène. Épiphénomène qui a pu avoir des conséquences absolument dramatiques et désastreuses.
Je remets pas ça en question, mais ça reste un épiphénomène. Et donc ça ne peut pas servir de lorgnette pour analyser la question des communautés musulmanes et de l'islam en Belgique et plus largement en Europe.
Donc ça reste un épiphénomène. Si on parle de -- je reprends les chiffres avec beaucoup de pincettes : 500 000, 600 000, 700 000, je n'en sais rien-
Mh
...personnes ayant un lien avec l'islam en Belgique. Vous voyez la proportion.
Quelles sont les pistes alors pour déconstruire ces a priori, ces clichés, ces stéréotypes négatifs ?
Les pistes pour les déconstruire, c'est évidemment, ben je pense qu'un exercice comme celui-ci, celui qu'on a ensemble, est extrêmement intéressant.
Déjà, avoir du temps, c'est extrêmement rare. Je vous l'ai dit en vous répondant, en répondant à votre mail.
C'est extrêmement rare. Aujourd'hui, on est amené-- d'abord, les experts sont convoqués pour analyser des situations à chaud.
Or, en tant qu'expert, en tant qu'universitaire, on a-- d'abord, on n'a pas la science infuse, on n'a pas les réponses à tout.
Et parfois, lorsqu'on est convoqué à chaud, il y a toute une série de choses qu'on ne sait pas et qu'on apprendra plus tard.
Et ça, donc c'est un exercice parfois d'équilibriste qui est de plus en plus difficile. Ensuite, la recherche, elle prend du temps.
Et nous sommes dans des sociétés où on a de moins en moins de temps. Il faut répondre à des questions complexes très vite.
Et parfois, on nous dit : « Bon écoute, Corinne, tu veux pas venir commenter l'actualité ? Voilà, t'auras 30 secondes dans tel créneau ».
Ben, je peux-- j'ai vraiment déjà essayé, mais en 30 secondes, je peux vraiment rien dire de très intelligent et de très intéressant.
Par rapport à cette actualité relativement récente de ces dernières années, est-ce que vous avez assisté dans votre milieu, donc l'étude de l'islam en Belgique, est-ce que vous avez assisté à un
renouveau d'intérêt ou bien est-ce que finalement, vous restez entre vous ?
Alors d'abord, je pense que ça fait 30 ans qu'on parle de l'intégration de l'islam et je pense que l'intérêt ne se démentira pas.
Il y a eu le 11 septembre, évidemment, l'intérêt a été exacerbé avec les départs en Syrie, avec les attentats. Alors oui, on voit des collègues dont ce n'est pas la spécialité s'intéresser à la question de la radicalisation.
Moi, je vois ça plutôt d'un bon œil. C'est-à-dire que je pense que les approches pluridisciplinaires, je pense qu'on est plus intelligent à plusieurs, en fait.
Plusieurs cerveaux autour d'une même table, ça fonctionne mieux que penser tout seul. Donc moi, je vois ça plutôt d'un bon œil.
Alors par contre, on voit des choses qui sont plus problématiques, c'est-à-dire des personnes qui ne font pas du tout de terrain sur cette question-là.
Être convoqué en tant qu'expert, souvent d'ailleurs, ça fonctionne assez bien, paradoxalement. Et ça, je pense que c'est problématique parce que ce n'est pas la dynamique de la recherche.
La recherche scientifique, elle s'appuie sur du terrain empirique, sinon elle perd son sens, et elle perd véritablement son intérêt.
Et donc vous, personnellement, vous allez sur le terrain, vous allez rencontrer, voilà, la population musulmane bruxelloise régulièrement ?
Alors mon terrain, oui, donc depuis que j'ai commencé en 2003, 2004, effectivement, je fais du terrain.
Alors des terrains qui sont différents. On avait commencé à parler de la question de la radicalisation. Donc
avec ma collègue Fabienne Brion, qui est professeure à l'UCL et sous sa direction, depuis plusieurs mois, on a entamé un travail de terrain, par exemple en prison avec les personnes
condamnées pour des questions de terrorisme.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est un terrain. Mais encore une fois, ça prend du temps, parce que ne serait-ce qu'obtenir des autorisations, ça déjà, ça prend du temps, ça prend plusieurs mois.
Donc voilà l'exemple d'un terrain. Mais moi, j'ai commencé mes recherches sur les mosquées, sur l'installation des mosquées.
Et donc oui, j'ai fait beaucoup de terrain dans les mosquées. Après, je me suis intéressée à la participation politique, donc j'ai plus travaillé avec
des représentants d'associations, d'ONG, des personnes qui étaient candidats dans les partis politiques.
Voilà différents terrains que j'ai pu mener. Alors nous, on a toujours une difficulté ou un regret, c'est qu'on peut pas tout faire en même temps.
Il y a beaucoup de choses à traiter, donc on ne peut que se réjouir de voir de nouveaux collègues arriver, d'avoir des doctorants, de nouveaux chercheurs, des étudiants aussi.
Moi, j'ai des étudiants qui font d'excellents terrains, voilà, s'ajouter justement aux experts et au terrains qui sont en cours parce qu'en fait on n'est pas excessivement nombreux en Belgique.
Mais donc vous, vous expliquez qu'il y a encore ce stéréotype négatif sur les musulmans, comme quoi on les associe à la violence et au radicalisme.
À l'inverse, à quoi est-ce qu'on assiste aujourd'hui comme tendance, entre guillemets, positive chez les musulmans et dont on ne parle pas assez ?
Eh bien, on a d'abord un féminisme musulman qui s'organise, qui est présent, qui fait entendre sa voix et qui, à mon avis, représente
plus de femmes, et même soutenues par certains hommes, que de personnes qui ont été séduites par la filière djihadiste.
Donc il faut pouvoir faire la part des choses. Et on voit plein de gens pour qui cette question de l'identité genrée ne pose pas véritablement de problème.
Donc je pense qu'il faut véritablement dissocier les deux, tout simplement.
Cette notion de féminisme musulman, est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler ? Ça m'intéresse.
Alors moi, je suis pas une experte de cette question-là parce que j'ai toujours pris soin de la mettre à distance et notamment de ne jamais travailler sur le foulard-
D'accord
...tout simplement parce que ça me semblait être une question-
Un champ de mine.
Oui, voilà, exactement. Le champ de mine. Le champ de mine par excellence, sur laquelle on s'écharpe assez fortement.
Oui parce que quand vous dites féminisme musulman, certains pourraient dire que c'est une forme d'oxymore, que c'est pas compatible.
Oui, mais il y a justement des travaux qui sont super intéressants sur cette question-là et des femmes musulmanes qui écrivent sur cette question-là.
Et je pense que ce-- on ne les entend pas, sans doute peut-être pas assez, mais justement, toute une série de femmes qui--
leur discours est de dire : « Ben en fait, nous, on doit se battre par rapport à deux formes de patriarcat.
» Le patriarcat intracommunautaire, beaucoup d'hommes, par exemple, vont quand même essayer de s'appuyer sur le religieux pour essayer de museler la femme.
Moi, j'ai toute une série de copines qui, par exemple, dans les mosquées,
vont un peu challenger les imams et, souvent encore les personnes de la première génération ou de la génération et demie qui tiennent encore les mosquées, en disant
: « Pourquoi est-ce que je pourrais pas prier dans la même salle que vous ?
Pourquoi est-ce que j'ai droit à la petite salle pourrie où j'entends pas l'imam, je vois rien, etc. ? » Alors que du temps du prophète ça...
Et elles vont les challenger.
Et elles ont des argumentaires.
Un exemple. Deuxième exemple, ben moi, j'ai des tas de copines qui portent le foulard et je peux vous assurer qu'elles font plus de trucs le soir, elles vont à plus de conférences que moi, elles vont à plus d'activités le soir que moi,
qui représente pourtant
sans doute le paradigme idéal de la femme libérée, blanche, portant pas le foulard, etc.
Eh ben, c'est vraiment un préjugé. Et donc elles disent : « Ben nous, on doit lutter sur ce patriarcat interne au sein des communautés.
Et puis il y a une autre forme de patriarcat qui a tendance à vouloir me libérer contre mon gré, c'est-à-dire à mon corps défendant et qui me dit : "Ah, tu portes le foulard, donc tu n'es pas moderne, donc tu es soumise, etc."
» Et qui sont aussi autant de poncifs et de préjugés. Alors, est-ce que le voile peut être un outil d'oppression ? Sans aucun doute.
Sans le moindre doute. Est-ce qu'il n'est que ça ? Non, sans aucun doute aussi.
Ce que nos sociétés doivent faire, c'est trouver le chemin entre les deux, c'est-à-dire pouvoir laisser
la liberté aux personnes et aux femmes qui sont majeures et donc vaccinées, de pouvoir faire leurs propres choix et de l'assumer et de pouvoir lutter contre toute forme d'oppression de femmes qui n'en feraient pas le choix.
Pour revenir à votre formule d'il y a un instant, est-ce qu'il n'est que ça ? Non, sans aucun doute. Qu'est-ce qu'il est d'autre à ce moment-là ?
Est-ce qu'il est un pilier identitaire ? Est-ce qu'il y a un attachement ?
Mais il est des tas, il est des tas de choses et je pense que c'est important de laisser à chaque femme le loisir, la possibilité, la liberté d'y mettre sa propre signification.
Moi, on me demande pas si mon jeans, il est militant, identitaire, etc. Et pourtant, je pense que j'ai un sens identitaire très fort par rapport à la manière dont je m'habille.
Parfois, passer par ses propres pratiques permet de mieux comprendre les pratiques de l'autre. Donc, il y a des tas de possibilités.
Il peut être culturel, il peut être identitaire, il est sans aucun doute aussi religieux, il est des tas de choses.
Il est parfois purement esthétique. Il est parfois purement lié à des questions de santé aussi, il faut pouvoir le dire, mais que chaque femme soit libre d'y mettre ce qu'elles veulent.
Et je trouve triste qu'en 2020, on doive encore insister sur la liberté des femmes à s'habiller comme elles le souhaitent.
On avait reçu dans cette émission Nadia Geerts il y a un an, qui tenait des propos assez différents des vôtres.
Ça ne m'étonne pas.
Mais voilà, mais donc chacun aura son point de vue en la matière. On avait aussi beaucoup parlé avec elle des notions de laïcité et de sécularisation en Belgique et en France.
Est-ce que, dans la population que vous étudiez, donc les musulmans en Belgique, est-ce qu'il y a une adhésion à ces principes de laïcité, de sécularisation ou bien pas du tout ?
Alors, les dynamiques d'individualisation dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure-
Oui
...eh bien, elles sont liées à cette question de la sécularisation. C'est-à-dire que donc on a d'une part cette individualisation dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure, je n'y reviens pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on voit aussi statistiquement ? Eh ben, c'est que la mosquée, en tant qu'institution religieuse, elle perd de sa capacité d'encadrement.
Et ça, c'est typiquement la dynamique de la sécularisation. C'est-à-dire que les institutions religieuses, on en a parlé un petit peu tout à l'heure ensemble, elles sont en perte de vitesse.
Ben, c'est le cas aussi au sein de l'islam. Et d'ailleurs, c'est reconnu par certains imams qui disent : « On a du mal, par exemple, à attirer les jeunes, etc.
Qui viennent pas. » Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on a beaucoup d'imams qui proviennent des pays d'origine,
qui parlent encore assez souvent, ça change un petit peu, mais souvent, on en a encore qui ne parlent pas beaucoup le français, le néerlandais, l'allemand.
On a trois langues nationales en Belgique, ne l'oublions pas. Et donc, ça veut dire qu'il y a des tas de gens, des tas de jeunes qui ne comprennent pas les prêches, qui ne comprennent pas les sermons.
Et puis, on a d'autres discours aussi qui disent : « Écoute, l'imam, il me parle, ça fait la quarantième fois-- » je caricature, je vais recevoir des emails très très fâchés, mais c'est pas grave.
« C'est la quarantième fois qu'il me parle de comment je dois faire mes ablutions. Mais oui, mais moi, la question qui m'intéresse, c'est la question de la discrimination, c'est la question du chômage.
Moi, je galère. Et donc, tu vois, mes ablutions, bon ben ça va, j'ai compris comment je vais les faire. » On a ces deux discours qui existent.
Moi, c'est des discours que j'ai beaucoup.
Et donc ces deux dynamiques,
individualisation d'un côté et difficulté d'encadrement du croire, ça veut dire que les imams, les prédicateurs, la mosquée en tant qu'institution religieuse a peu d'impact sur la construction de la foi,
eh bien, ce sont les prémices de la sécularisation.
Et donc c'est ce qu'on voit, c'est la lame de fond. Alors ça reste une tendance qui est très fragile,
mais c'est une tendance qu'on peut démontrer aujourd'hui statistiquement et qui n'est pas présente qu'en Belgique, puisqu'on a des rapports de recherche équivalents pour la France et équivalents pour le Royaume-Uni.
Donc ça, c'est pour la notion de sécularisation. Un autre mot qu'on emploie souvent pour parler de, je ne sais pas si ça veut dire quelque chose, mais la population musulmane belge.
Un autre mot qu'on entend souvent, c'est la notion d'intégration. Qu'est-ce que ça signifie l'intégration aujourd'hui ?
Alors, l'intégration, ça peut signifier plein plein de choses. C'est difficile de parler d'intégration à des personnes qui sont nées en Belgique.
Et je pense qu'on a toujours un prisme ou un tropisme en Belgique que moi, j'ai pu personnellement rencontrer.
C'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on parle des musulmans et de l'islam, on a tendance encore à se référer à une population étrangère.
Par exemple, on me dit : « Ah, mais donc toi, tu parles arabe ou turc alors pour tes enquêtes ? » Je dis : « Non, très très mal d'ailleurs.
» Mais ça me fait toujours sourire parce que moi, la plupart de mes enquêtés ne maîtrisent ni l'arabe ni le turc. Alors, c'est peut-être un peu moins vrai pour le turc, mais c'est très très vrai pour l'arabe.
Et donc ça me fait toujours sourire. Il y a une forme d'altérité. C'est toujours des populations qui viennent de loin, qui sont étrangères.
On oublie que ces populations, on en est à la quatrième génération. Elles sont nées en Belgique, elles sont socialisées en Belgique, c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont socialisées avant tout en français, en néerlandais, en allemand, peu importe.
Et je peux vous démontrer quantitativement qu'au sein des familles, on utilise de plus en plus le français, le néerlandais ou l'allemand comme langue de discussion avec les enfants.
Et donc on oublie ça.
Donc, mais donc, est-ce que ça voudrait dire que ce mot intégration cache finalement une certaine idée de normalisation, de…
Alors, tout dépend comment on va définir l'intégration. Et ce serait très intéressant, d'ailleurs, ce serait une vraie bonne question à poser.
Quand on a eu des hommes et des femmes politiques qui ont dit : « Voilà, l'intégration est un échec », mais qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient en tête ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils définissaient par le terme intégration ? On peut voir l'intégration comme une dialectique. Ça veut dire une discussion entre le groupe d'origine immigrée et la société majoritaire.
Ça veut dire que ce groupe maintient certaines pratiques et en adopte d'autres. Mais on peut aussi voir l'intégration comme étant l'assimilation.
C'est l'idée que les groupes issus de l'immigration perdent toute référence culturelle et religieuse. Très honnêtement, dans l'histoire des théories de l'immigration, ça se passe assez peu.
La sociologie de l'immigration, je terminerai là-dessus, elle est née aux États-Unis parce qu'on a constaté que les populations, par exemple d'origine européenne,
maintenaient des liens de solidarité, maintenaient des pratiques culturelles qui leur étaient propres.
Et on parlait de population européenne.
Donc, à Rome, on fait comme les Romains, ça ne marche pas, c'est ça ?
Exactement. Quel est le premier réflexe des Européens…
C'est une phrase que Éric Zemmour aime beaucoup.
Mais quel est le premier réflexe des Européens qui vont habiter au Maghreb ? C'est d'aller au Carrefour et de voir si on vend du porc et de l'alcool.
Je peux vous assurer que c'est l'un des premiers réflexes. Donc c'est évident qu'on a tendance à maintenir des pratiques culturelles et religieuses qui nous sont propres.
Ça fait partie de l'histoire de l'humanité et c'est universel.
Très bien. Un dernier mot pour conclure, un message que vous souhaiteriez adresser à nos auditeurs au sujet de votre spécialité, l'islam en Belgique ?
Alors, par exemple, de suivre un peu mon actualité parce qu'avec un peu de chance, je vais bientôt sortir un livre sur cette question, sur la question de l'islam en Belgique qui fera un petit peu la synthèse
de tout ce dont on vient de discuter, et que j'ai vraiment pensé comme un outil.
Voilà. Et sinon, le message plus général, c'est d'essayer de ne pas avoir peur de faire le pari du contact, et du pari d'aller vers l'autre.
L'islam, ce n'est pas que ce que les médias nous en présentent. Voilà.
OK. Pour suivre votre actualité, vous êtes sur Twitter, Corinne Torrekens. Et votre livre, c'est publié chez qui ?
Quand ? Quel titre ?
Alors, ça paraîtra, j'espère, encore cette année-ci, aux Presses universitaires de Bruxelles, donc les Presses de l'ULB.
OK. Pas encore de titre ?
Pas encore de titre.
Pas encore. Bon, mais ce sera pour bientôt. Corinne Torrekens, merci beaucoup d'avoir passé Septante Minutes Avec Moi.
Merci à vous.
Au revoir. Voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode. Avant de se quitter, je tenais vraiment à remercier les auditeurs et les auditrices qui m'ont envoyé des mots d'encouragement sur les réseaux sociaux pendant ces derniers mois.
Il y en a même qui m'ont écrit des pavés de texte en réaction à certains épisodes, preuve que ça avait quelque part suscité une certaine réflexion.
C'est vraiment adorable et c'est hyper encourageant. Donc merci. Dans une petite semaine seulement, je vais publier un épisode avec Jacques Balthazart.
Jacques Balthazart est neuroendocrinologue. Il a longtemps été professeur de biologie à l'Université de Liège et il étudie l'effet des hormones sexuelles sur le cerveau des animaux, y compris le cerveau humain.
Autrement dit, la semaine prochaine, on va se pencher sur les différences qu'il y a en général entre le cerveau d'une femme et celui d'un homme,
mais aussi sur la sulfureuse question de l'orientation sexuelle, puisqu'il nous expliquera comment ça marche à un niveau biologique.
Et c'était d'ailleurs le titre de son premier livre : Biologie de l'homosexualité. Donc ça, ce sera dès jeudi prochain. Et après ça, on aura normalement une journaliste belge expatriée pour nous parler de la Chine et de ses mystères.
Et puis enfin, je suis très heureux de vous annoncer que fin février, je recevrai l'économiste Bruno Colmant pour ce qui s'annonce comme un excellent numéro.
Merci d'avoir écouté jusqu'au bout et à très bientôt. Salut !